hello and welcome to this video playing
moss and something more so we've got the
Reggie opening sound solid good yeah so
we'll see 97 yeah really one I think
it's my repertoire move here 44 into an
important point is at sea takes Knight
takes 95 I have Queenie tool it's
something that is very important to
remember this move 95 is more of a
problem usually ok here it also would
work in Queenie tomb I don't know okay
'if five is also possible here
'if I've Bishop g2 EF six special of 6mm
could work I'm sure it all looks good
actually 2495 wins wins the queen or
other material may be can defend with
Queen d3 but it looks pretty awful as
well ok now we five forward of course he
also gave me the b5 square and I'm not
really sure why ok knight c6 now it's
very strong I think do I have something
better you know but it's a strong add
this is a disaster opposition winning
material already willing at least
exchange
black resins and yeah and it's a very
dangerous line for black heavy
especially if you don't know it yeah
does this does this and now i'm i'm not
quite sure if black is still able to
equalize to be honest it looks quite
normal but there are some tricks here 95
for example Queenie too is it's awful
for black a little bit at least offered
is strong but it's it's it's very
difficult for black to play this it
cannot take 495 yeah there are any
problems here don't quite remember or is
it night b5 actual you know it's 95 this
and then you can change this this is at
least possible which is enough to call
it off of a black tape like this not
sure here really not be force also move
that the engine suggest I didn't think
about that this i think i failed
shouldn't work and here 95 still looks
okay even though this is not bad but ok
this is also a good move he cannot take
I think I mean Jesus what I was thinking
and here I should have something get you
fired for example this bed of a white
least a bit yeah this is now getting
pretty dangerous and take he can go
Queenie 8 that doesn't lose material
immediately but poor that's not a sight
you want to see as black two nights
invading dangerously this is this
suppose this losses at least they
exchange and it's still a complete bind
on next position so
early resignation but it's definitely
not uncalled for okay guys thanks for
watching